ill ce matin Monsieur Patrick Martin
président du Mouvement des Entreprises
France Medef du Medef le président de la
Confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises à CPME Monsieur François
Asselin qui devant nous quitter sera
ensuite remplacé par Madame Stéphanie
posa vice-présidente qui sera en
visio et enfin nous accueillons le
co-président du mouvement des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire le M
Monsieur Philippe dornano merci à à vous
trois pour votre présence mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie très
sincèrement d'avoir répondu présent à
notre invitation nous souaitions en
effet recueillir pour la première
réunion plinière de notre délégation de
cette législature votre analyse de la
situation économique de notre pays et de
ses conséquences sur les entreprises
françaises la délégation aux entreprises
est une instance jeune tout juste 9 ans
mais elle a déjà travaillé avec une
grande énergie une détermination sans
faille pour mener à bien ses missions et
faire remonter les attentes et les
difficultés des entreprises not
territoire en particulier les TPE PME et
et
ETI votre présence ici monieur le
président est la preuve que le dialogue
direct que nous avons établi avec les
chefs d'entreprises est la clé du succès
des politiques publiques ayant un impact
sur les entreprises au service de
l'emploi et du développement économique
de notre pays comme mes collègues le
savent déjà je ferai de la
simplification le cheval de bataille de
mon mandat de président de la délégation
je déposerai prochainement d'ailleurs
une proposition de loi traduisant les
préconisations de mon récent rapport sur
la sobriété
normative mais en attendant je ferai
tout ce qu'il est possible de faire pour
palier les carences habissales des
études d'impact dans les projets de loi
qui nous sont soumis et pour cela je
vous propose de montrer au gouvernement
qu'il est possible de mettre en œuvre
des tests PME ainsi je solliciterai vos
organisations lorsque nous aurons besoin
d'une évaluation chiffrée fiable
réaliste pour apprécier l'impact de
certaines dispositions applicables aux
entreprises ce serait ainsi une
expérimentation précieuse pour l'avenir
si vous en êtes d'accord et vous pourrez
également nous apporter votre expertise
sur les prochains travaux de la
délégation qui concerneront on l'
désigné les rapporteurs ce matin le
foncier économique la directive dite
csrrd les entreprises et le climat et
enfin la la question du financement de
l'entreprise de
demain pour en revenir au sujet de notre
table ronde nous savons que la
conjoncture est difficile avec des cours
des matières premières qui reste élevé
des taux bancaires en hausse et un cadre
réglementaire toujours plus contraint
peut-être pouvez-vous chacun pour les
entreprises que vos organisations
représentent nous offrir votre regard
rétrospectif sur cette année 2023 et
surtout votre analyse prospective pour
2024 quels sont les défis majeurs les
priorités et les principales inquiétudes
des entreprises
françaises à cet égard le Sénat débutera
dans quelques jours l'examen du projet
loi de finance pour 2024 qui contient de
nombreuses mesures ayant un impact sur
les entreprises comme c'est de plus en
plus souvent le cas à forciorie avec le
recours à la procédure du 493 merci
avant même le début du débat budgétaire
cette année plusieurs dispositions
importantes ont été intégrées par
amendement sans étude d'impact ni examen
parlementaire approfondi je pense
notamment à des dispositions relatives à
l'augmentation du versement mobilité en
Île-de-France ou bien une nouvelle taxe
incitative sur les carburants nous y
voyons aussi quelques avancées positives
notamment sur le pacte du truil en
matière de transmission d'entreprise au
salariés si d'autres incertitudes
persistent sur d'autres amendements
concernant du truil ou concernant le
financement des jeunes entreprises
innovantes mais d'autres menaces
semblent se profiler et je vous
laisserai les évoquer en préparation de
l'examen du budget du Sénat nous
souhaiterions donc recueillir votre
sentiment sur ces nouvelles mesures et
si vous êtes en mesure de l' sur
l'impact concret qu'elles auront sur les
entreprises
françaises je vous laisse donc sans plus
attendre la parole pour un propos
liminire à peu près de 8 minutes chacun
afin de nous laisser la possibilité
d'échanger de réagir à vos propos é
entendu que nous devons conclure à
9h15 je rappelle que cette table ronde
est retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat puis en vidéo à la
demande ensuite je voulais juste
préciser à mes
collègues que si vous pensez pouvoir
poser des questions si vous avez des
questions à poser à nos intervenants il
serait bien dès maintenant au fur à
mesure de vous manifester auprès de
Stéphanie ou ou ou ou des autres
administrateurs qu'on puisse établir une
liste et avancer au fur à mesure merci
messieur je vous laisse la parole on va
commencer par vous Monsieur Martin merci
monsieur le Président bonjour mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs je suis très heureux de
pouvoir m'exprimer devant vous je
voudrais commencer par saluer vous vous
l'avez évoqué monsieur le Président le
récent rapport que vous avez produit
effectivement sur la simplification
administrative dont nous partageons
intégralement les analyses et les
propositions donc nous nous tiendrons à
votre disposition effectivement pour
travailler sur ces sujets qui sont
absolument centraux étant rappeler que
le Medef représente
190000 entreprises dans tous les
secteurs d'activité tous nos territoire
et avec un effectif moyen de 50
salariés nous av avons un une perception
en temps réel en réalité des sujets qui
nous occupent ce matin et sur lesquels
vous
m'interrogez je voudrais commencer par
attirer votre attention sur un point qui
me semble-t-il dans le débat public
français n'est pas suffisamment
souligné qui est l'écart qui se creuse
extrêmement rapidement entre d'une part
l'Union européenne d'autre part les
États-Unis et la Chine c'est assez
spectaculaire en matière de
d'investissement c'est assez
spectaculaire en terme de croissance
vous avez comme moi pris connaissance
des récents chiffres de croissance des
États-Unis plus 4,9 % déjouant tous les
pronostics mais au-delà de ça je
voudrais rappeler que si en terme de PIB
par rapport au PIB mondial l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis pèsent à
peu près le même poids de l'ordre d'un/4
en matière
d'investissement l'Europe ne représente
plus que 15 % l'investissement mondial
quand les États-Unis sont déjà à plus de
30 % et accélèrent extrêmement
rapidement ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que la période que nous traversons
au-delà de la conjoncture à proprement
parler se se traduit par un creusement
des écarts structurels entre nos
différents pays et quand je signale le
niveau extrêmement élevé et
l'accélération extrêmement soutenue de
l'investissement aux États-Unis je pense
à tous les secteurs d'activité on peut
parler de secteur dit traditionnel
l'automobile par exemple mais je pense
bien évidemment à des secteurs qui
engagent notre avenir dans le digital et
dans les biotechnologies je crois qu'il
faut qu'on ait tous en tête cette donnée
parce que nos débats franco-français
méritent d'être éclairé au regard de ce
qui se passe à l'échelle mondiale c'est
un premier point sur la conjoncture à
proprement parl il y a une dégradation
elle est quasiment généralisée le seul
secteur de notre point de vue qui
continue à se comporter de manière
extrêmement favorable et l'aéronautique
avec des carnets de commande à très long
terme et qui se remplissent jour après
jour donc d'une manière générale la
filière aéronautique est en bonne santé
même si tel ou tel de ces acteurs peut
éprouver quelques difficultés partout
ailleurs nous constatons une dégradation
que ce soit dans le dans la distribution
avec une une baisse de la consommation
une baisse en volume et progressivement
une baisse en en chiffre d'affaires que
ce soit dans l'industrie et que ce soit
dans les services de rénavant et puis de
manière absolument critique dans toute
la filière construction nous sommes
extrêmement préoccupés par cette
situation qui bien sûr impacte
directement les acteurs de la filière
construction le bâtiment tout son amant
industriel toute sa périphérie en terme
de service avec des perspeces
qui sont extrêmement préoccupantes en
terme d'activité juste pour situer les
choses notre pronostic c'est que au
global les activités du bâtiment entre
le U et la rénovation il y a une
probabilité de baisse d'activité de
l'ordre de 10
% si un secteur qui pèse 8 % du PIB
national est en baisse de 10 % si je
calcule bien c'est un impact sur le PIB
global de 08 points nous sommes assez
inquiets assez
d'ailleurs incompréhensif au regard
d'une forme d'inertie ou parfois même de
dénis de la part de l'exécutif
s'agissant de cette filière qui on le
sait dès à présent en 2024 détruirea des
emplois alors même qu'elle en a beaucoup
créé ces dernières années et que
notamment au titre de la rénovation
énergétique elle devrait au contraire
être en plein Bou je finis sur ce
développement sur le logement en
rappelant que bien sûr c'est l'enjeu de
la filière à proprement parler mais ça
va bien au-delà c'est un enjeu évident
enfin malheureusement pas évident pour
pour tout le monde en terme de pouvoir
d'achat bien sûr que nos entreprises
font leurs meilleurs efforts pour
revaloriser les salaires mais il serait
pas inintéressant de s'occuper de ce qui
représente 40 % des dépenses contraintes
des ménages modestes en tout cas et on
peut aussi agir si on veut développer le
pouvoir d'achat sur les dépenses autant
que sur les recettes et puis par
ailleurs c'est un enjeu absolument
critique en terme de mobilité
professionnelle je rappelle que 60 % des
salariés ou des chômeurs hébergés en
logement social se disprêt à renoncer
refuser une opportunité professionnelle
induisant un déménagement de peur et ils
ont raison de ne pas pouvoir se reloger
dans des conditions économique donc en
logement social donc un panorama
conjoncturel qui se dégrade je rappelle
que le PMI manufacturier n'est plus qu'à
42,6 points en baisse de nouveau sur le
mois d'octobre 1.6 éant rappeler que la
tendance de longue période c'est 50 donc
nous sommes significativement en dessa
de cette tendance de longue période et
au niveau le plus faible s'agissant de
ce pays IB manufacturier depuis le mois
de juin 2020 les services qui jusque-là
tenaient plutôt bien sont même en
dessous de la moyenne de de longue
période à
46,1 donc un climat conjoncturel qui est
préoccupant évidemment impacté par le
niveau des taux d'intérêts notre
pronostic étant je crois qu'il est
largement partagé que la Banque centrale
européenne après les 10 hausses auquell
elle a procédé de ses taux directeurs ne
baissera pas ses taux avant au plus la
fin du 1er semestre
2024 en regard nous sommes très
interrogatifs pour tout vous dire très
inquiets quant à un certain nombre de
décisions en cours d'examen ou d'ors et
déjà prises par les pouvoirs publics
notre premier sujet de de préoccupation
et l'étalement de la baisse de la
disparition de la CVAE je rappelle que
cette suppression de la CVE à hauteur de
9 milliards d'euros devait intervenir
intégralement 2023 dans un premier temps
elle avait été ét étalé sur 2023 2024 à
la fin des fins si les engagements sont
tenus cette suppression de la CVE sera
opéré sur 5 ans il y a de récents
rapports il dire une pile de rapports
qui établissent que la distorsion de
concurrence qui existe en la entre la
France et les pays voisins en matière
d'impôt de production est un un facteur
de
de dégradation de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises absolument
catastrophique il y a un deuxième
facteur de grande inquiétude qui qui ne
dépend si vous me permettez ni de vous
ni du gouvernement c'est le récent arrêt
de la Cour de cassation imposant de
reenavant des congés payés sur les
arrêts maladies alors c'est la
transposition directe en l'occurrence à
travers cet arrêt de la Cour de
cassation d'une directive on le sait
directive européenne qui date de 2003
c'est un coût annuel pour nos
entreprises de 2 milliards d'euros c'est
un renchérissement du coût du travail de
2 milliards d'euros sans parler de ce
que probablement nous serons tenus de
faire c'est c'est-à-dire provisionner
ces ces congés payés sur l'antériorité
en matière de prescription salariale
c'est-à-dire 3 ans il a tout lieu de
penser on le saura très rapidement que
les commissaires au compte imposeront
aux entreprises de provisionner donc 6
milliards d'euros au même moment où leur
compte se dégrade du fait de la
conjoncture énorme sujet de
préoccupation très sincèrement on ne
voit pas la on ne voit pas la solution
il y a par ailleurs un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives en cours
d'examen qui nous préoccupent beaucoup
je veux parler vous y avez fait
référence monsieur le Président à
l'augmentation du versement mobilité en
île-de-fance je rappelle que du seul
fait de l'effet base c'est-à-dire
l'augmentation de la masse salariale les
entreprises franiliennes qui d'ors et
déjà payent 5 milliards d'euros au
bénéfice des transports publics de
proximité auront une augmentation de ce
versement mobilité de 400 millions
d'euros la mesure qui est envisagée de
réhaussement du plafond déjà dérogatoire
du versement mobilité en île- de France
correspondrait lui aussi à une
augmentation du versement mobilité de
l'ordre de 400 millions d'euros et pour
être très franc même si les pouvoirs
public s'en défendre notre pronostic est
est que ce qui se passerait en
Île-de-France dans un premier temps se
propagerait à l'ensemble du territoire
national dans un 2è temps pour avoir
parlé avec Madame vassal à Marseille il
y a quelques jours elle attend avec
impatience la généralisation de cette
mesure en clair ça renchérirait le coût
du travail de 1 milliard d'euros par an
pour nos entreprises
grosse préoccupation également
s'agissant des propositions de du député
Marc ferci concernant le bandeau famille
les études sur lesquelles se fonde cette
proposition sont sont partielles je
rappelle que ell consiste à dire que les
allègements de charge sur ce bandeau
famille entre 2 et demi et 3 et demi SMI
n'ont pas eu d'effet en terme de
création d'emploi nous sommes très
dubitatif quant à ses conclusions mais
quoi qu' quoi qu'il en soit ce
raisonnement ne prend pas en compte
l'enjeu de compétitivité si cette mesure
devait effectivement être prise sous une
forme ou sous une autre elle impacterait
prioritairement les secteurs les plus
exposés à la concurrence internationale
je veux parler de l'industrie je veux
parler de l'ingénierie je veux parler
d'un certain nombre de de métiers de
service je veux parler également des
métiers financiers qui par excellence
sont exposés à la concurrence
internationale donc ce sera un nouveau
coup de canif dans la politique de
l'offre et une nouvelle altération de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises sur les
segments d'activités qui don le cadre de
l'économie de la connaissance alors même
que nous savons devoir tirer vers le
haut la valeur ajoutée de nos
entreprises sont les plus
déterminantes je continue mon inventaire
en vous signalant que nous allons devoir
procéder à une augmentation du taux de
cotisation AGS je sais que le sujet va
être évoqué dans un second temps c'est
évidemment lié à l'augmentation du
nombre de défaillances d'entreprises
lesqueles défaillances progressivement
touch une taille d'entreprise de plus en
plus importante et donc nous n'aurons
pas d'autrre solution c'est un régime
purement patronal je le rappelle nous
n'aurons pas d'autre solution que de
réhausser cette cotisation AGS d'un diè
de points pour être très clair là aussi
ça veut dire plus de 700 millions
d'euros d'augmentation du coût du
travail l'année prochaine si je mets
bout à bout ces différentes ces
différents facteurs dont je le redis
cette les conséquences de cet arrêt de
la Cour de cassation sans même que nous
ayons décidé la moindre augmentation de
salaire le coût du travail va augmenter
l'année prochaine de l'ordre de 4
milliards d'euros ça n'est pas le
meilleur moment je vais me permet de
vous inviter à être très attentif à tout
ce qui relève de la décision
législative deux autres points de
préoccupation évidemment les
financements alors les les chiffres les
chiffres d'une certaine manière sont
assez rassurant je veux dire par là que
les mises en place de crédit et les
demandes de crédit de la part des
entreprises ne s'effondrent pas on a
d'ailleurs vu le mois dernier que à
notre bonne et grande surprise le les
investissements des entreprises
continuaient à progresser mais il y a
malgré tout une restriction du crédit et
puis bien évidemment un renchérissement
du crédit il semblerait que cette année
les frais financiers représente dès à
présent plus de 10 % de l'excédent brut
d'exploitation des entreprises
c'est-à-dire tro à quatre fois plus que
leur niveau il a 3 ou 4 ans avec
évidemment des taux de référence qui
étaient historiquement extrêmement
bas l'énergie autre gros sujet de de
préoccupation la solution qui se dessine
au niveau européen et par ailleurs au
niveau français suis évidemment avec la
plus grande attention des discussions
entre l'État et lui-même je veux dire
entre l'État et EDF
sont plutôt encourageante mais il y a
lieu que les solutions se confirment dès
les prochaines semaines parce que c'est
évidemment un grand sujet de
préoccupation pour nos entreprises
celles qui sont plus exposées à la
concurrence internationale j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure la dynamique
d'investissement et de production aux
États-Unis ayons tous en tête que dans
certains secteurs les entreprises qui
ont la capacité sont d'ors et déjà en
train de transférer de la production et
des investissements aux États-Unis
pourquoi parce qu' il y a le le
dispositif puissant d'incitation à
l'investissement je parle bien
évidemment de l'inflation reduction Act
mais également le prix de l'énergie qui
demeure à ce jour trois quatre fois
inférieur à celui auquel on peut accéder
en France et dans l'Union européenne
donc grande attention s'agissant de ce
sujet de l'énergie enfin euh pour
surajouter je dirais aux préoccupations
qu'on les chefs d'entreprise euh les
débat en cours sur la remise en cause du
pacte du tril pour les entreprises
patrimoniales bien sûr sont extrêmement
préoccupantes et de nature à suspendre
un certain nombre de de décisions y
compris d'investissement donc pour me
résumer un panorama qui est assez
préoccupant alors même que nos
entreprises sont parfaitement
conscientes des opportunités de la
nécessité de se réinventer en
perspective de la neutralité carbone
alors même que nos entreprises ont en
interne des des talents remarqu
la France reste un pays extrêmement
innovant et alors même que la dynamique
de création d'entreprise en France reste
bonne il ne faudrait pas dissuader les
bonnes volonté je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
les sénateurs merci d'abord de de cette
rencontre c'est toujours important de
voilà de faire un point le plus
exhaustif possible je vais essayer de ne
pas trop répéter ce qu' dit Patrick
parce que sa présentation a été vraiment
très large oui ça ralentit
on a étit pendant la crise covid soutenu
hein et là faut pas se tromper
c'est-à-dire que lorsque on entend dans
les médias parler des milliards vers aux
entreprises soyons clair ces milliards
c'est à 90 % des mesures de financement
des mesures d'endettement il a fallu
décaler les charges sociales et fiscales
nous avons eu heureusement les prêts
garantis par l'État mais comme son nom
l'indique c'est un prêt et maintenant il
faut rembourser ces dettes donc les
entreprises n'ont pas encaissé sauf
celles bien évidemment qui étaient fermé
administr reltivement les secteurs S1 et
sbis rappelez-vous à l'époque les
restaurateurs il y avait pas d'autre
solution de toute façon mais pour le
reste à savoir l'immense majorité des
entreprises et bien maintenant nous
devons rembourser ce que nous avons
emprunté ou décalé dans un contexte où
l'activité commence à ralentir fortement
nous sommes d'ailleurs un peu surpris à
la CPME de voir la dynamique du du
ralentissement c'est c'est on a
l'impression que ça s'accélère ces
dernières semaines ça veut dire que
certaines entreprises qui était plutôt
solide euh à l'entrée de la crise et
bien commence à se fragiliser et on
commence à voir des problèmes de
remboursement de prètgaranties par
l'État pas simplement dans les TPE mais
aussi dans les PME ça monte en gamme si
je suis dire hein alors on se rend pas
trop compte parce que les chiffres
effectivement versés par la Banque de
France euh sont à peu près dans la
prévision à savoir 4,4 % de de sinistre
par rapport au prêts garantis par l'État
qui ont été souscrit par les entreprises
mais ce qui se passe en fait c'est que
les entreprises font tout pour
rembourser leur PGE et je vais expliquer
pourquoi elles font tout mais en même
temps elle commence et c'est pour ça que
je pense que sur l'investissement je
commence à être un petit peu inquiet
elle commence à figer tout ce qui
peut-être investissement
productif et pourquoi font-elles très
attention à rembourser leur PGE d'abord
parce que un chef d'entreprise aime bien
rembourser ses dettes premièrement mais
deuxièmement vouloir étaler son PGE
au-delà de la durée légale
d'amortissement et bien c'est la mise en
Banque de France de l'entreprise et vous
savez qu'une mise en défaut de Banque de
France d'une entreprise c'est la fuite
des assureurs crédit c'est l'accès au
crédit qui est terminé et donc c'est une
pilule létale même si et bien on va dire
on va vous accompagner et ben non
malheureusement c'est très compliqué de
s'en sortir c'est pour ça que depuis
très longtemps la CPME nous militons
pour faire en sorte et de façon on va
dire discrétionnaire il y a la médiation
de crédit qui peut s'en charger pour les
entreprises qui restent sur un marché où
il y a de l'activité un marché porteur
mais qui sont en situation d'endettement
où le seul problème c'est la durée
d'amortissement du pche je vous rappelle
c'est 2 ans de franchise plus 4 ans ou 1
an de franchise plus 5 ans et bien ne ne
pas pouvoir étaler sa durée cette durée
d'amortissement va malheureusement pour
certaines d'entre elles les mettre dans
une situation où elle aurait pu s'en
sortir mais là malheureusement il faudra
qu'ell aillent en procédure de
sauvegarde nous demandons donc de
pouvoir bénéficier de ces Têt allement
de la du remboursement du PG de manière
discrétionnaire il y a un blocage
européen j'étais à Bruxelles il y a 3
semaines pour évoquer entre autres ce
sujet je pense que nous pouvons y
arriver avant que la pression des
défaillances d'entreprise fasse que nous
soyons obligés de prendre ça dans
l'urgence voilà c'est un message fort
que je vous adresse sur ce sujet-là
sur sur la situation en fait on se
retrouve dans la période où il faut
purger la crise pendant 2 ans quasiment
l'économie s'arrête que l'on soit
salarié du secteur marchand
fonctionnaire retraité même demandeur
d'emploi ça tombe à la fin du mois même
indépendant c'est quand même
extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé bravo
la France finalement et bien aujourd'hui
et bien il faut bah purger cette crise
hein et et et la meilleure manière de de
la purger c'est bien
évidemment de toujours laisser intact
tous les leviers qui permettent
d'activer l'activité parce que pour
pouvoir rembourser ces dettes c'est le
cas du PGE il faut avoir de l'activité
on voit très bien que le moral des chefs
d'entreprise est intimement lié à leur
niveau d'activité quand le cas de
commande commence à se resserrer ou à se
vider et bien là vous avez des chefs
d'entreprise qui commence à être très
inquiet et je rebondis sur ce qu'a
expliqué avec Briot Patrick sur
l'activité de la construction du
bâtiment oui il y a un réel danger et
c'est une activité avec une forte
inertie c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui de
mon point de vue le coût négatif est
parti c'estàd quand bien même on prend
aujourd'hui des mesures dynamiques nous
allons en 2024 connaître une année
extrêmement périlleuse sur la
construction alors évidemment on peut
toujours évoquer le sujet que l'accès au
logement la construction est trop cher
mais Messieurs messieurs dames on a mis
en place tout ce qu'il fallait pour que
ça se passe mal voilà entre la oui ça
siffle c'est peut-être mieux merci voilà
entre bien évidemment le surenchissement
de surchérissement du de l'accès au
crédit
entre l'artificialisation des sols entre
le système normatif qui est un train fou
entre la transition énergétique avec la
mise en place des DPE et des mesures
coercitives mais qui est frais tout
propriétaire hein bah que voulez-vous
comment voulez que ça se passe bien ça
ne peut que se passer mal voilà donc là
il faut de mon point de vue se ressaisir
c'est pas qu'une question d'argent hein
il faut se raisir d'ailleurs c'est
étonnant on vous fait voter au Parlement
des lois d'exception parce que ben si on
applique la norme ça ne marche pas
écoutez il faudrait peut-être revoir la
norme quoi donc sinon on va faire que
des lois d'exception on saura plus
quelle est la norme hein donc c'est un
sujet un secteur sur lequel et bien il
faut franchement avoir un vrai point
d'attention et se
ressaisir dans les autres
sujets qui coûte beaucoup aux
entreprises mais qui ne rapporte pas un
€o à qui que ce
soit et donc qui coûte beaucoup au pays
c'est tout ce qu'on est en train de
mettre en place sur le système normatif
ou sur la loi et cetera il faut imaginer
que dans une entreprise patrimoniale et
même parfois dans une entreprise
importante et bien il y a un effet d'on
noir c'està-dire que on a une décision
qui arrive de la Chancellerie P on a une
décision qui arrive du ministère du
Travail on a une décision qui arrive de
ber je veux dire à l'arrivée dans la PME
c'est le chef d'entreprise qui doit
encaisser tout ça il n'a pas les
services je dirais à sa disposition pour
absorber toute je veux dire cette
avalanche de décisions qui parfois sont
incompréhensibles j'étais cette
semaine monsieur de Cambourg est venu me
rencontrer c'est le président de l'frag
à Bruxelles qui est en charge de
l'établissement de la norme CSRD pour
discuter avec lui d'une façon assez
serrée parce que ce qui est en train de
de se passer est quand même relativement
inquiétant on a dans notre pays
aujourd'hui je ne croise plus un che
entreprise qui ne se pose plus la
question de son modèle économique à
venir nous sommes tous convaincus et
tant mieux que demain il va falloir
produire différemment servir ses clients
différemment pour tenir compte et bien
évidemment la décarbonation de
l'économie hein donc c'est déjà une
magnifique prise de conscience une belle
victoire hein en
attendant pour engager tout le monde
dans ces transitions on
a écrit la norme CSRD qui va s'appliquer
pour les entreprises de plus de 250
salariés alors je rappellerai que une
entreprise de 250 salariés c'est c'est
pas une grande entreprise c'est une
grosse PME hein voilà faut pas l'oublier
he et et quand on regarde je me suis
penché le contenu de cette norme je peux
vous dire que c'est effrayant hein si
bien que nous avons des alérants hein et
et Philippe certainement pourra
témoigner aussi qui se sont engagés de
façon volontaire et tout à fait
remarquable dans la RSE parce que si
vous mettez la transition énergétique en
dehors de la performance sociale et de
la performance économique ben ça ne sert
à rien vous allez perdre tout le monde
he donc il y a eu des engagements
volontaires où ils ont emmené avec eux
tout leur personnel et aujourd'hui quand
il vait arriver cette nom CSD on va
perdre tout le monde c'estàd qu'il nous
ce poids administratif on veut pas le
basculer à nos équipes hein on est même
pas capable en interne de le tenir donc
il faut trouver les experts extérieurs
pour nous accompagner c'est pas sans
sans coût ça coûte cher voilà et pendant
ce temps-là ben il faut que l'entreprise
elle tourne hein est-ce que pour autant
ça fa accélérer les choses ch je je je
reste interrogatif et ce qui se passe
c'est que par ruissellement par
capillarité et bien comme toutes les
parties prenantes sont concernées une
PME qui est fournisseur d'une grande
entreprise commence on commence à lui
demander c'est même référentiel CCRD
parce que elle est partie prenante donc
nous on a des alérants qui nous disent
mais François mais c'est quoi ce bazar
quoi comment on va s'en sortir et
comment on va s'en sortir ben je le sais
pas trop mais mesames messieurs pourquoi
parce que le système financier bien sûr
doit enquiller la chose le système
assuranciel aussi donc si vous n'êtes
pas demain labelliser CSRD ou un des
labels qui va être volontaire mais qui
sera quasiment obligatoire pour les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés et
bien vous allez perdre vos clients vous
allez perdre vos banquiers vous allez
perdre vos assureurs voilà et pendant ce
temps-là aux États-Unis et bien ça
dans le bon sens voilà donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par rapport à
ça hein moi je pense qu'il y a deux
choses il y a même trois choses il y a
une chose qui m'a fait plaisir monsieur
le Président vous avez parlé du test PME
c'est quelque chose que l'on porte
depuis 2 ans maintenant je suis allé
rencontrer Thierry Breton pour ça il y a
un peu plus de 2 ans d'ailleurs hein
pour dire je je n'arrive pas à savoir
comment on peut arrêter ce tsunami
normatif hein et bien peut-être de se
dire avant de dérouler une norme hein et
bien si tout simplement parce que les
études d'impact on sait comment elles
sont faites hein elles sont faites pour
justifier une loi parfois injustifiable
mais bon voilà euh le test PME c'est un
une vraie étude d'impact de terrain ou
sur un panel d'entreprise volontaires et
bien on regarde si ce fchu fichu C SRD
fonctionne ou pas hein c'est il y a pas
de mauvaise volonté sur le terrain tout
simplement on veut-être entre guillemets
accompagné on veut être sollicité pour
savoir si ça peut fonctionner ou pas et
puis si ça fonctionne pas qu'on ait le
courage je dirais même parfois
l'humilité de revoir la norme voilà il
faut franchement s'appuyer sur la
confiance des chefs d'entreprise ils ne
sont absolument pas réfractaire au
changement mais ils veulent avoir des
choses qui sont compatibles avec leur
modèle économique et la vie de tous les
jours hein donc voilà sur le sur le CSRD
l'autre chose que l'on pourrait faire
c'est il y a il y a deux leviers sur
lesquels on peut jouer c'est la
temporalité et la méthodologie
temporalité si on va trop vite on va
perdre tout le monde deuxièmement et
donc il faut avoir une temporalité
compatible avec la taille des
entreprises la
méthodologie dans cette histoire vous
avez des branches professionnelles on en
connaitt à peu près une douzaine à la
CPME qui se sont engagés dans des
références de secteur volontaires hein
euh certaines ont même été labellisées
hein reconnu par des grands deur d'ordre
public je pense entre autres à l'UNICEM
c'est les carrières et matériaux qui ont
fait une démarche sectorielle RSE de
branche reconnu aujourd'hui par RFF hein
ça c'est intelligent pourquoi ça coûte
pas 1 € à l'état hein premièrement
deuxièmement c'est une démarche
volontaire où la branche professionnelle
va emmener toute seule tous ses
adhérents hein plutôt que de quelque
chose qui arrive d'en haut pourquoi à
travers pourquoi nous pourrions nous pas
faire à travers tout le dispositif CSRD
et et tout ce qui va au-delà s'appuyer
sur les branches professionnelles en
faisant des tests de branches à partir
de ces référentiels qui nous viennent
d'en haut voilà et là je pense qu'on
arriverait gentiment à ramener tout le
monde dans des choses on va dire
compatibles avec la réalité de terrain
voilà
sur les choses qui vont sur le champ
social qui vont qui percuteent sacrément
les chefs d'entreprise c'est clair que
cette histoire de jurisprudence sur les
congets payés c'est quand même
incroyable
c'est quand même incroyable vous rendez
compte c'est choquant bien évidemment
sur le fait que ça va coûter 2 milliards
d'euros sans compter la rétroactivité
potentielle qui on est en train de faire
une analyse juridique et làdessus
l'exécutif nous a pas démenti pour
monter voir jusqu'à 2009 la
catastrophe mais audelà du coup ce qui
est quand même incroyable c'est mais
mais on est sur un combat de valeur du
non travail produit des congés pendant
que des types qui qui reste au boulot
bah vont avoir leur congé point pas plus
que ça mais mais et moi j'en ai parlé à
mes petits camarades syndicaux je dis
écoutez mais là-dessus quand on se voit
on est quand même là pour parler du
travail défendre le travail je dis mais
mais là-dessus on devrait avoir une
position collective en disant ouais il y
a un momentù faut rater le compteur et
ben non et ben non après tout c'est
àquis et ben tant mieux tant mieux pour
ceux qui vont en profiter mais c'est une
catastrophe parce que c'est une une
perte totale du bien commun voilà donc
il ne faut surtout pas baisser les bras
la CPME a lancé une pétition parce que
il faut que nous maintenions la la
pression nous voulons que le
gouvernement et bien prenne à bras le
corp ce sujet je sais parce que j'ai eu
Elisabeth borne j'ai eu Olivier du sopte
là-dessus je sais qu'ils sont vraiment
comment dire embêtés avec avec avec
cette jurisprudence mais pour autant
nous ne vons pas baisser les bras je
pense qu'on peut arriver par la loi
contingenter le nombre de congés on a
quelques idées je pense qu'on peut
arriver à amortir le coût que ça va
représenter et surtout et bien retrouver
un petit peu du bon sens dans tout cela
hein au-delà de ça je voudrais vous
évoquer un sujet aussi qui est très
amant pour les entreprises et les
entrepreneurs c'est l'article 39 du
PLFSS vous savez qu'il a été retiré
c'està le 39 reprenez une des
dispositions de l'accord national
interprofessionnel que nous avons signé
entre partenaires sociaux euh sur les
CAES d'accident du travail et maladie
professionnell euh dans cet accord ATMP
avec les partenaires sociaux nous avions
fait en sorte euh que euh suite là
encore à une jurisprudence malheureuse
vous savez que sur la faute inexcusable
sa peut-être pas mais je vousoulais
expliquer je vais essayer d'être court
depuis 1898 entre partenaires sociaux
nous avons mis nousous sommes mis
d'accord donc il y a très longtemps pour
en fait mutualiser le risque accident du
travail pour que lorsqu'il y a un
accident du entreprise un salarié puisse
être
indemnisé depuis 1898 et ça c'est
vraiment vertueux et bien ensemble nous
cotisons à travers nos caisses àmp pour
que lorsqu'il y a un accident un salarié
puisse être indemnisé avoir une rente à
Vie pas simplement pendant sa carrière
professionnelle mais jusqu'à la fin de
ses jour voilà une jurisprudence a fait
tomber cette mutualisation en disant que
il faut la réparation pleine et entière
et que grosso modo il faut aller au
tribunal pour réclamer une réparation
pleine et entière alors là je vous
explique pas en matière d'accident ça
peut dépasser toutes les limites
imaginables on parle en millions d'euros
parfois nous avons dans cette Annie avec
les partenaires sociaux et c'est
explicite rétabli l'ordre des choses en
sécurisant la faute inexcusable et
d'ailleurs à travers cette année on a
augmenté les rentes pour bien donner un
geste au SAL
victime d'accident du travail l'article
39 reprenait le fruit de cette Annie et
malheureusement par la pression de gens
qui ont fait leur boulot auprès des
parlementaires des associations mais
aussi les partenaires sociaux qui sont
pas neutres là-dedans et bien les
parlementaires se sontrouvé devant entre
guillemets une grande question est-ce
que cet article 39 est valide ou pas et
finalement le gouvernement a décidé de
retirer cet article 39 les conséquences
pour nous peuvent être dramatiques
pourquoi parce que demain imaginez en
cas d'accident du travail et bien un
employeur ne sait pas à combien il peut
être condamné et ça peut-être violent
donc c'est la fin d'une entreprise sur
une petite
entreprise
deuxièmement comment s'assurer demain
pour couvrir ce risque les primes d'
l'assuranceces vont exploser hein et
troisièmement quand vous rajoutez
l'article 39 plus les conget payé mais
on fragilise le statut de salarié
comment voulez-vous qu'à côté de cela ne
se développent pas des dérives
et demain si on arrive pas à régler tout
ça le combat du patronat ça sera de
demander d'éviter la
requalification parce qu'il y aura pas
d'autre solution donc il faut retrouver
du bon sens dans tout cela voilà le
message que je voulais vous porter vous
savez que en France on garde quand même
un tissu économique et d'entreprise et
d'entrepreneurs de grande qualité je
vous je vous le confirme je vous
l'affirme on a simplement besoin d'une
chose parfois c'est peut-être
excusez-moi mais une PSE législative
ou en tout cas de se dire mais attendez
temps mort regardons ce que l'on peut
faire pour tout simplement garder intact
l'envie
d'entreprendre merci Monsieur le
présidentelin je voulais juste avant de
donner la parole à Monsieur le Président
dorano accueillir et souhaite la
bienvenue à Madame Stéphanie PAA
vice-présidente de la CPME et qui
prendra notamment les questions de quand
vous serez parti monsieur le Président
de des différents sénateurs à vous
monsieur le Président bonjour Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénateur
merci de me recevoir moi je vais vous
donner peut-être pour compléter un peu
le propos de de Patrick et François Le
l'angle ETI les ETI vous le savez c'est
des entreprises de 250 à 5000 salariés
de de de 00 millions 1 milliard et demi
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires c'est les
les entreprises moyennes grandes qui
font le le tissu économique de nos
régions alors un chiffre on avait autant
de ces de ces entreprises en 1980 qu'en
Allemagne de l'Ouest aujourd'hui on a
5500 et en France contre 13000 en
Allemagne 10500 en Angleterre 8500 en
Italie et 73000 aux États-Unis pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a un tel écart comment
est-ce que comment est-ce que cet écart
s'est creusé dans ces 35 dernières
années avec cet écart également la
désindustrialisation et d'une certaine
manière l'appauvrissement de nos de nos
territoires la perte de nos savoir faire
c'est la question autour de laquelle on
s'est nous regroupé sur lequelle on a
travaillé deux deux combats nous ont
nous
ont permis de à notre sens commencer à
redresser la situation le premier c'est
de permettre les transmissions
d'entreprises l'une des raisons de cette
défaillance française c'est le blocage
des transmissions d'entreprises entre 80
et 2000 dont les packs du TR qui ont été
qui ont été mentionné et le deuxième
c'est d'avoir un écosystème français où
on puisse travailler et
produire aujourd'hui en France on nous
avons créé un écosystème une sorte de
système de droit de douane à l'envers
qui fait qu'il est plus coûteux de
produire en France que de produire dans
l'environnement européen voire même dans
l'environnement mondial et ça a déjà été
dit alors face à ça les se dernières
années ont été plutôt positives on a eu
une inversion de de la situation et on a
eu un effort qui a été fait à travers un
certain nombre de mesures qu'il faut
saluer pour permettre de revenir à un
écosystème qui soit raisonnablement
aligné sur l'environnement européen
toute une série de mesures de
réalignement de l'IS de début d'une
baisse des taxes de production dont on a
dit l'écart qu'il a avec l'environnement
européen la le une taxation des
dividende qui a permis notamment de
refavoriser des transmissions
d'entreprises 150 % de pack du tray
signé en plus depuis la le
pfu une baisse des des charges sociales
qui a été commandé commencé il y a à peu
près 7 ans sur les bas bas salair et les
salaires intermédiaires qui a permis de
réaligner en partie le coût du travail
qui est qui est qui était qui était
beaucoup plus fort que dans
l'environnement européen aujourd'hui
vous avez encore deux écarts principaux
vous avez un écart important sur les
taxes de
production et vous avez un écart
important sur le coût du travail et
notamment le coût du travail qualifié
cet écart il se chiffre à 80 à 100
milliards d'euros c'estàd que les
entreprises françaises payent 80 100
milliards de plus que celle de leur
environnement européen ce qui rend leur
situation moins compétitive et ne leur
permet pas de prospérer de se développer
à l'égard j'ai d'ailleurs cité l'exemple
de l'Allemagne 13000 ETI il faut savoir
que ces ETI en plus de ça sont deux fois
plus grande donc deux fois plus grande
plus de recettes fiscales plus de plus
d'emplois moins de moins
d'investissement moins de transferts
sociaux une économie qui est plus
dynamique il y a pas de miracle allemand
il y a plutôt des défaillances
françaises euh face à cette situation
donc on a donc pris un certain nombre de
mesures et ces mesures donnent des
résult
moi je ne suis pas surpris de voir la
poursuite des investissements je ne suis
pas surpris de voir la baisse du chômage
c'est le résultat de cette politique et
on pourrait se dire on met on met en
place les premières mesures de
réalignement compétitif on mesure le
résultat elle donne des résultats on va
donc poursuivre et en fait ce qu' nous
constatons à l'heure actuelle c'est deux
choses d'abord vous l'avez dit une
tension assz assez forte pour des
raisons qui sont exogènes à la France
tension géopolitique
inflation refermement aussi un peu du
monde qui qui fait que que que un
certain nombre d'entreprise se retrouve
se retrouve avec des marchés qui se
referment et dans des situations plus
difficiles on en reparlera hausse du
coût de l'énergie donc une situation qui
qui se tend et face à ça alors même
qu'on voit les premiers résultats de la
politique qui a été de la politique qui
a été mené un et ça a été très frappant
ces derniers mois plutôt plutôt que
accéléré on ralentit on en revient à la
situation passée et là on a eu toute une
série d'alertes dans dans dans dans ce
dernier mois qui sont qui sont
extrêmement qui sont extrêmement
inquiétantes et que et que je voudrais
je voudrais citer d'abord le
ralentissement de la baisse des taxes de
production soit dit en passant les taxes
de production il existe maintenant
depuis 2 ans un indicateur global de
taxes de production vous avez sans doute
Notter que c'est les taxes de production
en valeur n'ont pas baissé elles sont
toujours à 80 milliards d'euros malgré
les les baisses de certains impôts les
taxes de production en recette n'ont pas
baissé le le danger aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y a toujours 30 milliards d'écart
avec l'environnement européen si on
n'est pas capable de poursuivre ce ce
redressement compétitif qui va donner
des retours sur investissement et qui en
réalité ne va pas coûter au budget de
l'État et même probablement lui
rapporter quand on prendra toutes les
externalités positives que que en terme
d'emploi en terme d'investissement en
terme de développement des entreprises
en terme de recettes fiscales que que
ces mesures rapportent on on voit que en
réalité les taxes de production les
taxes de production on devrait plutôt
continuer à les baisser et pour le
moment on ralentit on ralentit la baisse
de ces taxes deème deuxème sujet le coût
du travail
qualifié on voit que là on commence à là
aussi ralentir sur le réalignement du
coût du travail qualifié or une
entreprise elle fait son succès avec
toutes ses équipes mais particulièrement
justement avec ses ouvriers qualifiés
dans l' industrie avec qui sont bien
payés avec ses cadres avec ses
chercheurs avec ses équipes qui
travaillent à l'export c'est c'est ça ce
qui permet à une entreprise de se
développer si cette part des des
salaires si un ingénieur coûte beaucoup
plus cher en france ben vous allez avoir
une entreprise française qui qui va
avoir moins de résultats donc qui va
avoir moins de moyens de se développer
c'est le c'est donc un deuxème point
d'alerte trème point d'alerte et ça a
été mentionné par mes collègues la
transmission
d'entreprise euh les les les les mesures
qu'on nous annonce risquent de regripper
la transmission d'entreprise il faut le
dire très clairement et la transmission
d' entreprise elle est clé une ETI sur 2
va se transmettre dans les 10 prochaines
années une ETI sur 2 de notre capacité
collective à gérer ces transmission
d'entreprise on va construire le mle
stand français de demain ou pas euh et
aujourd'hui en France notre performance
en terme de transmission d'entreprise
est l'une des plus mauvaises d'Europe 20
% contre 60 % en Italie donc cet enjeu
il est considérable et face à ça il
faudrait non pas freiner de nouveau mais
plutôt accélérer c'est-à-dire aligner
les transmissions d'entreprise là encore
sur l'environnement européen elle coûte
deux fois et demi plus cher aujourd'hui
la transmission aujourd'hui en France
elle est possible depuis les PAC du tril
elle est plus coûteuse que dans
l'environnement européen une une
entreprise française qui se transmet en
moyenne elle doit solliciter euh elle
doit elle doit mobiliser entre 6 et 10
ans de ses profits selon son modèle son
modèle économique donc on est encore
encore dans une situation qui est
sérieuse en terme de transmission
d'entreprise et et pour arriver à la
taille eiste un chiffre qui peut-être
vous intéressera aussi il faut en
moyenne en France 21 ans donc pour
arriver à ces 50 millions pour
construire les ETI du tissu économique
régional pour construire aussi les
grandes entreprises de demain il faut du
temps alors je dis pas que toujours les
entreprises peuvent se transmettre je
dis pas que jamais elles doivent se
vendre je dis par contre que les bloqués
dans leur transmission pour des raisons
uniquement fiscales c'est une erreur
économique majeure dont nous payons
aujourd'hui
le le le coût qui qui comp tenu du
blocage qu' a eu notamment entre les
années 80 et 2000 3ème point à notre
sens d'attention c'est mais ça a été dit
je le choc de complexité je je donne
simplement un chiffre pour les les ETI
les mesuré à 26 milliards
d'euros là c'est le CSRD moi pour pour
l'avoir regardé dans mon entreprise les
premières simplement les premières
études sur l'adaptation du du CSRD à une
une moyenne ça se chiffre en centaines
de de milliers d'euros
donc prenez prenez ça et appliquez-le à
des entreprises industriel et ca ne
croyez pas que ça va pas toucher les PME
parce que bien sûr ça va avoir des
effets de bord les entreprises vont vont
se retourner vers leur vers leur le
leurs fournisseurs et vont et vont
demander toute une série d'informations
donc vous avez un choc on est face à un
choc de complexité et un surcût sans
mesure d'impact qui va être considérable
donc c'est c'est ça va être un sujet ce
sujet de la complexité qui est qui est
complexe à traiter il est pourtant vital
et il est extrêmement coûteux et puis le
dernier point que que je voulais
mentionner avec vous c'est le le sujet
de de l'énergie il a été aussi mentionné
d'abord ne croyez pas que le sujet de
l'énergie est derrière nous la plupart
de nos entreprises elles ont signé des
contrats donc aujourd'hui elles achètent
l'électricité à des prix qui sont très
au-dessus non seulement des Américains
mais même des mais même des Allemands de
l'ordre du double on est passé d'un pays
qui qui avait une une un prix de
l'énergie qui était là par contre un des
rares avantages de compétitivité à un
pays où où l'énergie maintenant dégrade
la compétitivité française donc ce sujet
de l'énergie je veux pas rentrer dans
dans le détail du débat et dans la
négociation sur les prix sur et le sujet
des des prix mais le sujet de l'énergie
il est absolument vital pour pour pour
la production en France je dis même pas
pour les entreprises français je dis
pour la production en France et et donc
ça c'est un point de compétitivité qui
qui est à notre sens extrêmement
important de nouveau et pour conclure
nous les le retour qu'on a de nos de nos
membres c'est que la situation se tend
beaucoup euh c'est qu'on est dans une
situation qui est dégradée et
l'inquiétude qu'on a vis-à-vis de tout
ce qui a tous les amendements qui ont
été proposés le PLF c'est qu'on est
alors même qu'on a des résultats
probants alors même qu'on a une
politique économique qui une une
inversion finalement de ce qui s'est
fait pendant 30 ans et pour la première
fois on était rentré dans un cercle
vertueux où on commence à réaligner
compétitivement la France sur l'économie
européenne brusquement on s'arrête et on
s'arrête au plus mauvais moment donc il
y a une un vrai vrai sujet et un vrai
enjeu merci euh monsieur le Messieurs
les Présidents pour vos propos plutôt
très éclairant alertant et ce qu'on peut
toujours apprécier avec les chefs
d'entreprise c'est hyper précis et sans
trop de littérature ce qui nous va très
bien on va maintenant passer au aux
différents échanges et on va commencer
par une première question notre collègue
euh Michel canev merci monsieur le
Président je remercie également la
représentante des organisations
patronales pour ce tour de d'horizon
extrêmement intéressant surtout à un
moment où on examine les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale et le
projet de notre finance ici au Sénat je
veux dire que la délégation sénatorale
aux entreprises a beaucoup travaillé sur
les questions de de formation et de
compétences qui sont
essentielles au premier semestre 2000
2023 et nous avions mis en évidence
notamment la nécessité de pouvoir
maintenir les moyens dédiés à
l'apprentissage on est en particulier
très heureux que l'amendement qui avait
été porté par la Délégation aux
entreprises dans le texte sur le plein
emploi et pu concernant la limitation
des des prélèvements sur France
compétenence par l'État a pu être
conservé dans par la commission mixte
paritaire ceci étant on a vu que des
vééités sont apparu à l'Assemblée
nationale lors de
l'examen du du du plnf sur des
amendement tendant à limiter pour les
entreprises de plus de 250 salariés ou
pour les jeunes suivant des formations à
bac+ 2 les aides à l'apprentissage et je
voulais savoir quel était votre point de
vue même si le gouvernement l'a pas
retenu semble-t-il dans le texte issu du
493 quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
et de manière générale sur
l'apprentissage est-ce que l'on doit
baisser la garde ou est-ce qu'en
contraire il faut qu'on continue à à
accroître
l'effort merci monsieur le sénateur
alors al ma réponse est catégorique il
ne faut pas remettre en cause ce
dispositif en l'occurrence d'aide à
l'apprentissage en toute matière il peut
y avoir des effets d'bè en toute matière
faut-il pour autant mettre en cause le
dispositif alors je ne me connais pas
qu'en réalité le succès collectif massif
que nous avons rencontré sur
l'apprentissage intéresse surtout des
formations dans l'enseignement supérieur
et quand on regarde la démographie des
des apprentis c'est vrai que pour à peu
près 80 % entre eux ils ont plus de 20
ans c'est un raccourci ça veut pas dire
qu'ils sont nécessairement dans des
études supérieurs et que ceux qui ont
moins de 20 ans ne sont pas dans des
études supérieures quand ils sont au
précoce je pense que c'est le dernier
moment pour remettre en cause ce
dispositif au motif de corriger
d'éventuels et d'effectifs d'ailleurs
effets d'Ain j'ajoute
que ça
impacterait des secteurs d'activité de
par la taille des entreprises et ou le
niveau de formation qui serait pris en
considération qui parur ailleurs au
titre de la remise en cause ou de
l'écrêtement des allègements de charge
sur le bandeau famille qui par ailleurs
seraient les les principaux concernés
par cette éventuel écrêement écrêement
dont on ne sait pas s'il interviendra
uniquement 2024 ou s'il serait prorogé
sur sur les années suivantes or je le
redis on parle là des secteurs
d'activité qui tractent le plus
l'économie française ça n'est pas un
jugement de valeur de ma part on a
besoin de de de métiers à forte
intensité de main d'œuvre dans les serv
de santé et cetera et cetera mais n'en
meure pas moins que les secteurs les
plus impactés seraiit
l'industrie serait les métiers
financiers serait l'ingénierie donc
autant de autant de professions qui je
le redis sont les plus exposés à la
concurrence international et je voudrais
terminer mon propos je sais que ça
parlera à certains d'entre vous élus
dans des territoires frontaliers il se
trouve que moi-même je suis originaire
d'un territoire frontalier en vous
citant un seul chiffre à ce jour
la Suisse fait travailler
quotidiennement 100000 travailleurs
frontaliers français quand on regarde
les niveaux de qualification on les
trouve à tous les niveaux de
qualification et n demure pas moins que
les gros bataillons de ces frontaliers
sont plutôt sur des niveaux de
qualification assez
élevés le gouvernement suisse le patron
de la Suisse ont annoncé que à un
horizon de 10 ans maximum ce ne serait
plus 100 mais 200000 frontalier dont la
Suisse aurait besoin et je ne parle que
de la Suisse donc si de par sa
compétitivité sal sa capacité à former
et à conserver des des jeunes de bon
niveau si la France ne s'arme pas pour
parer en définitive ce risque qui est un
risque parmi d'autres et bien nous
n'aurons que ce que nous méritons
c'est-à-dire une économie locost et le
départ de nos compétences ou de nos
industries vers des pays y compris
voisins merci monsieur le Président on
demande peut-être à Madame
laa
ah on vous entend pas
Madame est-ce que votre micro est bien
allumé refons un
essai vous m'entendez mentendez on vous
entend
merci vous m'entendez bien là vous
m'entendez bien
là et pour le coup parce que depuis le
début
C par
Reise ce que je souis
jeis TPE
PME le fait don don
accè permis à beaucoup
d'
Catez
[Musique]
prendre allezer vous vous allez aussi le
faire accompagner par une entreprise de
communication mais ça permet tout de
même à l'entreprise de créer son poste
et ensuite éventuellement d'Er son
collaborateur donc nous au niveau de la
CPME on pense qu'il ne faut surtout pas
toucher aux aides à l'apprentissage et
on voit aussi pour que que pour tous les
métiers
autres ça
permet un une meilleure intégration dans
l'emploi au niveau des entreprises autre
chose le fait d'avoir l'apprentissage
sur l'enseignement supérieur permet
aussi à des à des des des des étudiants
qui n'auraient pas forcément les moyens
d'accéder à ces études d'y
accéder
ces apprentissages dans les entreprises
et leur demander de ce ce qu'ils pensent
de ces dispositif ça ça permet aussi aux
jeunes d'avoir une vision concrète et
donc aussi en terme de formation d'avoir
une vision concrète couplée à leur à
leur à leur leur école de ce que c'est
que le travail dans l'entreprise donc en
terme de formation c'est très utile pour
eux aussi je pense que ce serait une
erreur profonde de revenir sur ce
dispositif il faut au contraire le
péréniser merci monsieur le Président on
refait un essai du côté de Madame posa
je sais pas si c'est prêt pour l'instant
la régie pas encore interven bon la
régie régie n'est pas encore intervenue
on va on va poser on va passer à la
deuxième question Monsieur Daniel
Laurent la Charente Maritime oui
monsieur le Président monsieurés le
micro le micro Daniel décidément on a
des problèmes avec les micros ce matin
merci pour vos exposés très enrichissant
il y a un sujet que vous avez abordé un
petit peu mais c'est surtout la main
d'œuvre vous êtes vous êtes conscient
mais nous le sommes tous des problèmes
récurrents de main d'œuvre que nous
avons dans tous les secteurs en France
quel qu'il soit petite moyenes et
grandes entreprise alors vous parlez de
l'apprentissage bien sûr c'est important
et très important et et tant mieux si ça
fonctionne il faut prendre les les les
les jeunes à la base mais par contre on
sait que le taux de chômage se maintient
un tôx assez constant on a certainement
un potentiel d'emplois qui ne sont pas
suffisamment formés donc c'est aussi lié
à la formation et j'aimerais bien que
vous nous en parliez et et pourquoi nous
nous je vous interpelle là-dessus parce
que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que nous
sommes en train d'étudier actuellement
la loi migration avec la question de
dire est-ce qu'on doit pas rentrer
beaucoup plus d'étrangers en France pour
justement répondre à la demande des
entreprises donc c'est un sujet
récurrent euh merci de me répondre sur
ce sujet qui est certainement important
pour l'avenir de nos
entreprises merci monsieur le sénateur
et je sais que cet honorable maison
s'occupe beaucoup du texte immigration
en ce moment du célèbre article 3
existera-t-il n'existera-t-il pas nous
suivons ça avec attention
oui enfin je je je je crois comprendre
que de l'autre côté ils veulent le
restaurer bon enfin ça ça dépasse ma
condition non je je vais vous répondre
le plus précisément possible sur ce
sujet l'immigration je voudrais malgré
tout commencer par vous dire combien
nous sommes en soutien de la réforme des
lycées
professionnels et ça les deux sujets ne
sont pas déconnectés si vous me
permettez ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que
euh bien sûr qu'il faut il faut se
pencher sur le sujet d'immigration
économique le MDEF n'a aucune vocation à
s'exprimer sur le sujet global de
l'immigration c'est bien l'immigration
économique qui peut nous occuper mais
commençons par le commencement d'une
certaine manière je veux dire par là que
on a sur le territoire national peu
importe leur nationalité
on a une masse de de personnes qui sont
éloignées de l'emploi si vous me
permettez l'expression il faut déjà
commencer par couper le robinet les
lycées professionnels je me garde d'en
faire une généralité nous connaissons
tous les lycées professionnels dans nos
territoires les lycées professionnels en
moyenne des cas sont quand même
d'extraordinaires machines à produire de
l'exclusion pourquoi parce que c'est
encore dans l'imaginaire collectif et
donc dans les fites à un moment donné
considéré comme une voie d'échec moi je
suis très frappé par ça ce débat sur les
lycées professionnel alors même qu'on
parle de 650000 jeunes alors même que
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le sénateur
on a encore des tensions de recrutement
extrêmement fortes à tous les niveaux de
qualification dans toutes les
professions ce sujet des lycées
professionnels n'est absolument pas pris
en compte par les commentateurs par les
médias et par un certain nombre même de
chefs d'entreprise pour une raison bien
simple parce que nos enfants ne sont pas
dans les lycées professionnels moi je me
risque à parler des lycées
professionnels avec un certain nombre de
journalistes ça ne les intéresse
absolument pas on a donc là un énorme
très beau sujet euh le mdev sera très
mobilisé en soutien de de cette réforme
des lycées professionnels ce dont nous
rêvons d'une certaine manière c'est de
réussir cette réforme aussi bien que
nous avons réussi la réforme de
l'apprentissage et donc nous nous
impliquerons très fortement en amont sur
l'orientation nous nous impliquerons
autant qu'on nous en laissera la place
dans la gouvernance de ces lycées
professionnels il y a des bureaux des
entreprises qui ont été créé mais à V
dire personne ne sait très bien en quoi
ça consiste et nous nous impliquerons
beaucoup dans l'accueil des des lycéens
professionnels en stage comme nous le
faisons dorén avant massivement pour les
apprentis à proprement parler et enfin
nous nous impliquerons dans le
recrutement de ces 650000 jeunes le jour
venu dès lors qu'ils auront été orientés
vers des métiers formés à des
qualifications qui correspondre au
besoins de l'économie je crois que c'est
un sujet très positif nous allons nous
intéresser ça va être une épreuve de
force pour nos entreprises évidemment à
l'inclusion des titulaires du RSA nous
allons nous intéresser il le faut
beaucoup plus massivement à l'accueil
des des jeunes scolaire et lycéen en en
stage ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que si on réussit déjà à traiter le
sujet de ces personnes sur le territoire
national éloigné de l'emploi le sujet de
l'immigration économique sera relativisé
j'ajoute que les réformes de l'assurance
chômage qui ont été menées par ce
gouvernement et qui je dois le
reconnaître ne sont pas le fruit de
d'accord nationaux interprofessionnels
parce que comme on pouvait s'en douter
le craindre d'une certaine manière les
organisations syndicales ne sont pas
très allante quand il s'agit d' dururcir
les conditions d'indemnisation du
chaumage euh ce régime d'assurance
chaumage mériterait d'être consolider
encore que je m'explique il y a encore
des poches il y a des des poches
d'opportunités je dirais dans le régime
tel qu'il existe actuellement qui
permettent à certains je pense aux
intermittents du spectacle en
particulier de bénéficier de régime
anormalement
favorable s'agissant à proprement parler
de l'immigration économique c'est un
sujet sur lequel ça ne vous a pas
échappé nous sommes relativement mal à
l'aise pourquoi parce que ce sujet est
totalement passionnel idéologisé
politisé et dès lors que le patronat
s'exprime sur ce sujet on n coupe pas
l'extrême gauche nous soupçonne de
vouloir faire baisser les salaires
l'extrême droite nous soupçonne d'être
les partisan d'une immigration massive
et incontrôlée la réalité des choses
quelle est-elle la réalité des choses et
je reviendrai sur le cas spécifique et
ultr sensible évidemment de la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier la réalité des choses c'est que
la dém phie qui est quand même une une
science lourde et exacte nous conduira
inéluctablement à faire appel dans
l'avenir plus encore qu'aujourd'hui à
l'immigration quand bien même je l'ai
évoqué nous aurions renforcé améliorer
doper notre système de de formation
initiale et
continue nous ce que nous appelons nos
vœux c'est d'abord mais c'est peut-être
une vue de l'esprit à ce jour c'est
c'est d'abord que nous dépassionnions ce
débat et que nous l'objet tivion si je
ne me trompe pas à ce jour l'immigration
économique ça n'est que 10 % des flux
migratoires donc il y a 90% des flux
migratoires sur lesquels les citoyens
sont les chefs d'entreprise ont un avis
mais les entrepreneurs à proprement
parler n'ont pas de légitimité à
s'exprimer sur les 10 % qui restent et
qui pourrait être en valeur absolue plus
dans l'avenir je crois que nous n'y
couperons pas il est impératif que nous
nous organisions pour identifier les
besoins et les anticiper le plus
possible les besoins à tout niveau de
qualification parce que chacun attendra
pas vous mesdames et messieurs mais nos
concitoyens ont tendance à penser que
l'migration ne porent que sur des
faibles qualifications la réalité quelle
est-elle c'est que sur des niveaux de
très haute qualification on a et c'est
déplorable et ça renvoie d'ailleurs à ce
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure sur le
coût du travail qualifié en France on a
par voie de conséquences sur les
salaires nets que peuvent percevoir des
des des salariés de très haut niveau de
qualification
on a des départs massifs en particulier
vers les États-Unis ça c'est intéressant
dans avant nos ingénieurs ne vont plus
tellement en Californie dans le digital
ils vont à Boston dans les
biotechnologiesé et le nucléaire en
apathie en regard et je peux vous citer
des cas extrêmement précis Philippe tu
le ferais beaucoup mieux que moi
probablement pour ta propre entreprise y
compris en regard on a les pires
difficultés du monde à faire rentrer en
France des candidats à l'immigra
eux-même de très haut niveau de
qualification donc d'un côté je force le
trait d'un côté on se vide en réalité de
de salariés de très bon niveau de
compétence d'un autre côté on nous
empêche d'en faire venir à un moment
donné il faut pas s'étonner que sur
certains métiers dans certaines
discipline et bien la France se dégrade
parce qu'à la fin des fins on peut pas
parler de l'économie de la connaissance
sans avoir de sachant d'ailleurs c'est
vrai dans le secteur public comme dans
le le secteur privé donc voilà nous ce
que l'on souhaite c'est un système
disons à la Canadienne voilà et je pense
que les Canadiens alors qu'il n'ont pas
la même histoire qui n'ont pas la même
géographie ont réussi à gérer ce ce
sujet d'autres pays l'ont fait également
de manière assez posée sereine et en
anticipant après sur la régularisation
des des S papiers euh moi j'entends bien
tout ce ce débat sur l'appel d'air que
que ça
créerait clairement appliquons déjà dans
toute sa dans tout son son potentiel la
circulaire Val se revue et corrigé le
cas échéant on est très frappé de voir
que d'un département à l'autre
finalement les préfets ont des positions
extrêmement disparates et à vrai dire
assez incohérente et je pense qu'on a
déjà là un potentiel de de solution je
termine en vous disant que il faut
également que on ait une doctrine
traduite ou pas dans les textes beaucoup
plus clair en
particulier sur le renouvellement des
permis de séjour dans beaucoup de nos
entreprises nous formons des jeunes ça
renvoie à ce que pu dire sur
l'apprentissage notamment nous formons
des jeunes étrangers qui donnent entière
satisfaction et qui au terme de leurs
études alors même que nos entreprises
souhaitent les embaucher ne voit pas
leur permis de séjour reconduit donc là
on marche un peu sur la tête on se prive
de compétences on a fait des
investissements en matière de formation
voilà pour me résumer ce qu'il faut ce
sont des réglages très opérationnels et
puis qu'on évite autant que possible de
se faire embarquer dans des polémiques
purement
politiciennes
madame madame PAA on va voir si la Régie
a remis en
ordre alors est-ce que vous m'entendez
sans écho oui on vous entend très bien
merci Merci à VOUS euh donc sur
l'apprentissage je me permets d'y
revenir donc nous au niveau des des TPE
PME hein au niveau de la CPME comme je
le disais tout à l'heure il est très
important pour nous euh que les les
aides à l'apprentissage demeurent pour
différents motifs d'une part ça permet
l'accès à nos TPE PME
euh à à à des d'accéder à des
collaborateurs qui soient à la fois sur
le terrain et en entreprise euh d'autre
part ça permet en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement supérieur parfois de
créer des postes dans la TPE PME euh je
j'ai pris tout à l'heure l'exemple mais
mais vous m'entendiez plus de la
communication on n'a pas forcé forcément
de de de de de service de communication
dans nos entreprises compte tenu de
notre taille et le fait de pouvoir
prendre un
apprenti qui a un niveau master et de le
faire accompagner d'ailleurs à côté par
une entreprise de communication permet
souvent la création du poste et puis ça
permet aussi à des jeunes d'accéder à
des études dont il n'auraient pas
forcément accès par faute de moyens pour
financer les études supérieures
puisqu'on sait tous qu'aujourd'hui ça
coûte quand même assez cher
euh ensuite donc sur j'ai pas très bien
entendu les sujets que que que Monsieur
sénateur souhaitait aborder mais j'ai
entendu Patrick Martin donc je vais
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Patrick Martin
concernant la la réforme sur les lycées
professionnels euh bien sûr nous nous
nous nous investirons également très
fortement dans la réussite de cette
réforme parce que nous y avons tout
intérêt euh les les la la l'image de
l'entreprise et et la la la nécessité de
recruter de nouvelles compétences et
notamment des jeunes dans les différents
secteurs d'activité nous pousse aussi à
réussir cette réforme de lycée
professionnel et nos entrepris joueront
le jeu sur l'accueil de stagiair bien
entendu concernant la la migration
économique donc là je rejoin
complètement ce ce qu'a dit
préalablement Patrick Martin pourquoi on
s'exprime peu sur le sujet parce que ça
ça fait souvent l'objet de débat très
passionné et très politique et et et là
ce n'est plus du ressort de l'entreprise
et du
patronnat nous ce qui nous paraît
important c'est que un travailleur
étranger une personne étrangère pour une
bonne intégration il y a
trois choses qu'il faut bien avoir en
tête il faut d'une part lui donner les
compétences nécessaires d'autre part
qu'il a accès à la langue du pays et
d'autre part qu' les aussi des bases sur
la sur la citoyenneté et la façon dont
on vit dans notre dans dans nos pays il
est très important pour nous en tant que
PME TPE de de de pouvoir
intégrer de nouveaux salariés quel
qu'ils soi et de leur donner toutes les
chances de
réussite vous savez que dans beaucoup de
métiers il y aura une pénurie de main
d'œuvre et ça peut être une réponse en
revanche il faut le faire pour que
l'intégration soit complète et faire en
sorte aussi qu'il n'y ait pas une épée
d'amoclesè un risque pénal qui pèse sur
la tête sur la tête du
dirigeant un point de vigilance aussi
c'est ne pas complexifier trop les
choses
euh on voit qu'il y a la création de de
nouveaux titre métier en tension carte
talent il faut faire attention à ce que
quand on demande la régularisation
tion des des personnes il ait pas un
risque supplémentaire aussi bien
d'ailleurs pour la la personne physique
le collaborateur qui est là mais aussi
pour pour l'entreprise enfin concernant
l'apprentissage de la langue française
nous ce que nous pensons c'est que c'est
le le un sujet de société qui qui
revient complètement au pouvoir public
en revanche ça nous paraît important
tout de même que l'entreprise a des
moyens des outils à disposition pour
pouvoir euh répondre parfois dans le
cadre de formation de avec la branche et
cetera alors est-ce que c'est via le CPF
est-ce que c'est des outils qui
pourraient passer par les OPCO ça reste
à débattre il existait il existe encore
les
MCCP qui sont la maîtrise des
compétences clés pourquoi ne pas
développer des outils similaires sur
euh l'apprentissage de la langue et et
je je crois que ça existe déjà dans
certains secteurs mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi ne pas le généraliser et
favoriser le comment dire le financement
de ces outils notamment via le fleu
merci beaucoup merci Madame PAA monsieur
le Président d'Ornano alors ça
pardonnez-moi de vous le dire comme ça
mais assez rapide et se prépare à poser
leurs questions et on en terminera là
après Franck Ménonville île bleuven et
Pierre creepers on posera les trois
questions ensemble si je vous demanderai
d'être très concis chers collègues de
manière à ce queon ait également des
réponses concises parce que je vous
rappelle qu'on a une deuxème table mon
dans la foulée merci pour compléter
simplement de ce qui a été dit plusieurs
plusieurs remarques premièrement c'est
vrai on a des métiers en tension et pas
que des métiers non qualifiés on a
beaucoup de métiers en tension très
qualifiés donc c'est l'économie des bons
salaires aussi he c'est des c'est ce
qu'on qu'on devrait tous ai souhaiter
construire la France d'une économie des
bons salaires deuxièmement en face de ça
on n'est pas dans la situation de la
Suisse hein on a encore 7 % de taux de
chômage et 2 millions de personnes si ma
mémoire est bonne qui sont pas du tout
qui sont hors du du scope ce qui c'est
d'ailleurs un sujet assez terrible et
dont on on devrait se on devrait se se
préoccuper d'où d'ailleurs l'importance
de construire l'apprentissage d'inclure
très vite les jeunes dans dans
l'environnement de de travail parce que
le travail c'est un peu comme le sport
c'est un rythme si vous incluez pas les
jeunes dans le alors qu'ils sont encore
jeunes dans dans le travail après vous
les perdez et après vous vous retrouvez
avec des gens qui sont complètement hors
du marché du travail et qui sont plus
difficilement employable et pour lequel
les efforts pour pour être employaablees
sont beaucoup plus importants donc avant
même tout autre discussion il y a il y a
il y a énormément de gens aujourd'hui
qui il y a d'une part un besoin de des
offres d'emploi qui sont non satisfaites
et en face de ça il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont pour le moment pas pas de pas
d'emploi qui sont donc en plus à la
charge de la collectivité il y a un
effort qui est à la fois un effort dans
les entreprises et qu'on mène et
d'ailleurs le plein emploi la première
chose c'est que ça oblige les
entreprises à faire beaucoup d'effort et
et quand vous trouvez pas quand vous
trouvez pas les gens bah justement vous
allez vousz vous allez essayer de faire
des formations inter vous essayé de de
de faire une partie du travail il y a
aussi un vrai travail un vrai
investissement de de un vrai question
qui nous nous échappe en tout cas en
partie même si comme l'a dit Patrick sur
les lycées professionnels il y a un vrai
engagement qui pourrait qui pourrait
être pris mais sur l'éducation d'une
part arriver à à former les jeunes pour
qu'ils soient qui sachent lire et écrire
la fin de la en 6e qui sacheent qui
sachent qui puissent arriver sur le
marché du travail raisonnablement
préparé et puis peut-être aussi c'est
beaucoup moins souvent dit un sujet sur
la santé sur laquelle parce que un C
nombre de gens qui sont inemployables
c'est aussi lié à des problèmes de santé
donc il y a aussi des efforts à faire
dans dans ce ce ce domaine là mon
troisième commentaire c'est que il faut
il faut il faut aussi collectivement
rendre le travail attractif et le
travail attractif c'est le travail pour
les gens qui rentrent dans l'emploi à
des bas salaires par rapport à
l'assistance c'est aussi comme l'a dit
Patrick le travail pour on a énormément
de jeunes très qualifiés qui s'en vont
parce que parce que le travail en France
pour pour des des jeunes qualifiés est
pas très attractif alors c'est normal de
partir quand on est jeune on peut aussi
voir le voir voir le monde et peut-être
qu'on revient mieux formé mais mais là
ce qu'on voit c'est c'est c'est une
France pour le travail qualifié qui est
qui devient pas très attractive et ça il
faut que collectivement on s'interroge
sur ce sujet parce que parce que c'est
un un vrai problème nos entreprises avec
la montée avec l'évolution économique
elles vont avoir besoin de plus en plus
mais tant mieux c'est l'économie des
bons salaires de travailleurs de
travailleurs d'employés de salariés
d'équipi qualifié donc c'est vraiment
important qu'on prenne ça en
considération j'espère que j'ai pas été
trop loin merci monsieur le Président
euh donc Franck Ménonville ensuite Yve
bleen et Pierre creepers s'il vous plaît
chers collègues il nous reste quelques
minutes si on veut laisser la
possibilité à nos à nos intervenants de
de répondre faites le plus concis
possible merci merci président très
rapidement et notamment pour rebondir
sur les les propos et l'intervention du
du président Martin je voudrais revenir
sur l'arrêt l'arrêt de de la Cour de
cassation et notamment qui qui donne qui
donne obligation de de de droit à la au
conget payé euh en cas d'arrêt maladie
bon j'aiétéis approché bien évidemment
par votre mouvement au niveau
départemental par Tiry Jung et par les
responsables du Grand Est c'est
extrêmement pénalisant au niveau
national c'est plus de 2 milliards
d'euros quelles sont les les les
solutions qui qui pourrai être proposé
et
on va prendre les questions dans la dans
la foulée donc Yve bluen oui Yve blven
sénateur du morbillant rapidement de
constats vous l'avez dit le logement qui
rentre dans une crise longue et grave
avec un parcours résidentiel
complètement stoppé une machine à
produire du logement qui s'arrête et en
même temps des entreprises qui sont
plutôt volontaires et on est assez
surpris et agréblement surpris dans
Bretagne de voir des entreprises
chercher des solutions
pour aider les collectivités à trouver
des solutions
logement mais on n' pas forcément tous
les outils je pense aux foncières je
pense au
démembrement de la propriété enfin on a
besoin d'inventer les outils en
parallèle de ça la loisan a obligé la
mise en place des stradet la Bretagne a
adopté son stradet au mois de juin et on
est dans l'exercice compliqué de la
répartition des enveloppes et on
commence à s'en
excusez-moi sur la figure pour se
partager le foncier et on voit bien que
là évidemment la concurrence entre le
foncier habitat et le foncier économique
et de va être le sujet numéro 1 on a
commencé comme dans l'habitat à parler
de bail à
construction certaines intercommunalités
annoncent aux entreprises que les
terrains seront proposés aux entreprises
sous forme de bail à construction quand
on arrive là sur le sujet du logement
sur le sujet des des zones d' activité
économique n'est-il pas temps d'inventer
l'outil ou les outils collectifs entre
vous entreprise nous collectivité pour
imaginer de mieux gérer le bien commun
demain parce que ce bien commun le
foncier c'est devenu une Drée rare il va
falloir qu'on le gère de façon
collective mais je pense que on n pas
les outils on a besoin de les imaginer
ensemble merci Pierre merci Président je
me dépêche
oui je vrais parler de la compétitivité
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure avec ça
a été dit par le président aselin sur la
le tsunami normatif est-ce que vous
pouvez préciser si c'est ce sont des
normes françaises qui se rajoutent aux
normes européennes et et parce que à ce
moment-là la compétitivité si on était
tous aux mêmes normes on serait bien sûr
dans une situation plus agréable ensuite
deuxème point la souveraineté nous avons
perdu la souveraineté énergétique nous
sommes en train de perdre la
souveraineté
alimentaire comment vous voyez vous de
votre côté la possibilité de redresser
la barre et de reprendre la main
justement sur cette question et puis une
question qui me chagrine c'est le PGE et
voir de quelle manière l'état réagit et
quelle conséquence aura plus précisément
si vous pouvez pas nous apporter la
réponse maintenant de N le faire par
écrit Merci Merci donc donc voilà la la
la la la sollicité tion de pierre est
intéressante aussi si on essaie de faire
de manière concise et après on pourra
revenir par écrit sur des précisions
plus importantes pour répondre aux
différents sénateurs merci plus de temps
oui alors si vous me permettez une
cadence de mitrailleuse euh bon cours de
cassation on sait que c'est la
transposition en l'occurrence directe
par la Cour de cassation de cette
directive européenne de 2003 que dans le
consensus je dirais les pouvoirs publics
et les les entreprises n'avaient pas
souhaité transposer euh les voies de
passage sont extrêmement étroites du
fait que c'est fondé sur un texte
européen et nous on n'a pas compris que
le l'Union européenne était prête à
revenir sur cette directive donc ça a
été évoqué par François Asel on va
essayer d'édulcorer en bonne
intelligence avec les pouvoirs public le
ministère du Travail en particulier euh
le ministère de la Justice on va essayer
d'édulcorer le l'impact de cette
disposition en prenant effectivement
appuie sur deux choses la première c'est
que on le sait tous le nombre de congéss
payés le nombre de jour de congé payé en
France est supérieur significativement
d'ailleurs à ce qu'on observe dans
d'autres pays donc ça veut dire que si
on peut se caler en définitive ne
serait-ce que sur une moyenne de de
jours de congé payés à l'échelle
européenne ça par définition ça
plafonnerait l'impact de de cette
dépense supplémentaire de cette charge
supplémentaire et le deuxième axe sur
lequel on travaille c'est que le le le
l'indemnisation des arrêts maladies est
supérieure en France à ce qui existe
dans les autres pays donc on va essayer
de jouer sur ces deux curseurs mais je
je suis désolé de vous dire ça nos
adhérents sont très impatients de
d'avoir des réponses et sont très
frustré qu'on apporte pas des dès à
présent des réponses moi je je je suis
très réservé quant à notre capacité à
trouver des solutions et françoiselin
l'a dit je le confirme nos
interlocuteurs syndicaux avec lesquels
d'une manière générale la relation est
assez bonne nous disent écoutez nous on
a encaissé la réforme des retraites vous
encaissez les les congés payés sur les
arrêts maladies bal au centre bon c'est
un peu c'est un peu désevant mais enfin
ils sont dans leur rôle donc voilà moi
je je ne vois pas de je ne vois pas
d'issue satisfaisante et sincèrement
c'est systémique c'est c'est c'est
dramatique ce qui se passe là et qui
vient se conjuguer je vais pas reprendre
tout ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure avec
d'autres d'autres mesure à l'étude ou
d'ors et déjà arrêté mais qui elles pour
le coup sont pas d'inspiration
européennees bien deuxème point sur le
logement ça mériterait un développement
beaucoup plus long moi je voudrais ça
n'est pas exactement votre question ni
votre remarque
moi je voudrais attirer votre attention
sur le fait que quand on regarde
l'origine de l'augmentation massive du
taux d'épargne des ménages bien sûr des
ménages plutôt aisés une bonne part
s'explique par le fait qu'il il
n'investissent plus dans l'immobilier
pour une raison très simple très simple
c'est que ça n'est plus rentable
d'investir dans l'immobilier quand vous
conjuguez le renchirissement du foncier
des coups de construction le
renchérissement de la fiscalité parce
que quand vous êtes dans de si vous
investissez dans le le l'immobilier
locatif par
définition c'est c'est fiscalisé au
titre déjà de la taxe foncière et ainsi
de suite et si mais ça c'est un problème
de riche si par ailleurs vous êtes
assujetti à l'IFI à forceie si vous êtes
auutau plafond d' fi vous investissez
vous perdez de l'argent au premier euros
d'investissement dans l'immobilier donc
je pense si ça été proposé par un
certain nombre de fédération notamment
la Fédération des promoteurs immobiliers
que au stade où nous en sommes pour
faire revenir de
l'investissement locatif privé il faut
des il faut des mesures choc il a été
évoqué ce qui avait été fait en 1993 si
j'ai bonne mémoire c'est-à-dire des
abattements sur donation dès lors que
les montants concernés serai consacrés à
l'immobilier locatif il a été évoqué le
statut de bailleur privé je crois qu'il
faut véritablement un choc pour faire
revenir déjà l'investissement privé ces
débats sans fin sur le Pinel c'est
insupportable quoi parce que ça crée une
instabilité qui de aux yeux des des
investisseurs pour un investissement qui
par nature est un investissement long
c'est extrêmement dissuasif voilà après
qu'on imagine d'autres dispositifs et
typiquement ce que vous avez évoqué oui
enfin ça relève si vous voulez de la
même temporalité de ce qu'imagine par
exemple le président de la République
qui m'a dit je la solution c'est de
révolutionner les techniques de
construction il a probablement raison le
problème il est demain il est
aujourd'hui il est pas dans 5 ans dans
10 ans ou dans 15 ans donc il faut ça
n'exclut pas de travailler sur des des
solutions de moyen et long terme mais
dans l'urgence voilà euh
sur sur les normes moi je voudrais
simplement rappeler que l'Union
européenne au cours des 5 dernières
années a produit 850 normes applicables
aux
entreprise donc si vous me permettez
l'expression il y a un délire normatif
qui est très partagé entre l'Union
européenne et l'État français donc pour
ce qui concerne le MDEF moi je considère
que il va falloir que nous soyons
beaucoup plus présents
à Bruxelles pour imposer en quelque
sorte un principe de réalité parce qu'il
a cette espèce de naïveté béate jusqu'à
une période récente en tout cas des
instances européennes aussi bien la
commission que le Parlement et donc il
est il est grand temps de il est grand
temps qu'on éclaire un certain nombre de
de décisions je prends un seul exemple
devoir de vigilance le devoir de
vigilance c'est c'est presque la
caricature cruelle de ce qui se passe je
rappelle que le devoir de vigilance le
texte qui est à l'étude et qui est bien
avancé d'ailleurs au niveau européen est
d'aspiration
françaisein c'est la célèbre loi Sapin 2
et euh dans le dans l'état d'esprit qui
est le nôtre celui de nos gouvernants
évidemment la France doit faire école à
l'échelle mondiale et avec une forme de
naïveté il avait été dit ben finalement
si le si l'Europe transpose sapin d'
purement et simplement c'est très bien
parce que nous l'avons déjà et ça nous
mettra sur un pied d'égalité avec nos
nos concurrents européens en
l'occurrence bon à part que le devoir de
vigilance c'est une singularité
européenne les Américains avec qui je
parle sont ébahis ils ont la même
réaction que à l'époque les Allemands
quand nous avons instauré les 35 heur
dit que c'était une excellente nouvelle
les Américains se disent que le devoir
de vigilance est une excellente nouvelle
mais là où ça se score c'est qu'en
définitive si le texte qui est à l'étude
au niveau européen s'applique il
s'appliquera pas de la même manière dans
tous les pays européens puisque en
France et par exemple pas en Allemagne
il y aura également des sanctions
pénale et donc c'est le principe de
précaution puissance 15 pour dissuader
l'investissement ou tout simplement
l'entrepreneuriat privé il y a pas mieux
donc nous pour illustrer mon propos la
nouvelle directrice générale du Medef
qui arrive lundi prochain et tout
simplement la conseillère Europe du
président de la République moi j'ai mis
en place une équipe Europe qui est
extrêmement musclée il faut qu'on ait
tous en tête là aussi la distorsion
moyens qui existe auprès des instances
européennes entre d'une part les ONG
d'autre part les entreprises et si on
parle des entreprises entre les
différents patronats les Allemands d'ors
et déjà nos amis d'ailleurs du du BDI
sont C fois plus nombreux à Bruxelles
que nous ne le sommes donc il faut
absolument qu'on rééquilibre ça mais à
la fin des fins c'est le même combat en
France et en Europe c'est le combat que
vous menez remarquablement avec le
rapport que vous avez produit et les
suites que vous entendez y donner nous
serons très en soutien
merci monsieur le Président on est
vraiment vraiment pressé par le temps
cette fois-ci madame PAA après monsieur
dornano pour terminer s'il vous
plaît on vous entend pas Madame
posa non visiblement il y a vraiment un
dysfonctionnement bon
monsieur s'il vous plaît monsieur le
Président de ronano je juste compléter
quelques éléments ce qui a été très bien
dit par Patrick euh le premier point
c'est que sur la partie coût coût du
travail cette cette norme européenne ce
ce c'est c'est c'est c'estes congés sur
les AR et maladie ça vient dans un
contexte français qui est défavorable
c'eston a un contexte européen général
le contexte français il faut le rappeler
quand même en moyenne européenne c'est
21 % de charge patronale en France c'est
41 % en moyenne certes assez compétitif
sur les B B salair mais dès que vous
sortez des bas salaires ça devient pas
compétitif du tout et c'est 45 % sur les
cadres 45 % sur les cadres et à ça à ça
pour que vous compreniez bien il faut
rajouter 30 milliards de taxes de
production qui sont qui sont basé sur la
masse salariale c'est un/ers des taxes
de production sont basés sur la masse
salariale donc en réalité on se trouve
on n'est pas à égalité du tout on est on
est dans une situation qui est dégradée
et dans cette situation dégradée on nous
on nous applique une norme européenne
supplémentaire juste pour vous donner
cette cet éclairage sur les transpos sur
le sur les le règlementaire nous avons
on a le le pire du pire parce qu'on a la
réglementation la surréglementation
française la qui s'applique que à nous
la surréglementation européenne qui
s'applique qu'à l'Europe mais comme tu
tu l'as dit qui qui touche pas le reste
du qui est pas du tout concerne pas le
reste du monde et et puis en plus de ça
on a un troisième point c'est la
surtransposition française sur des
règles européennes et on fait mieux on
veut être le mieux du mieux euh et ça
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président en tout début de de de de de
de présentation sans aucune aucune étude
d'impact on fait aucune étude d'impact
alors je vous prends pour compléter
aussi sur sapin 2 par exemple la loi
Sapin 2 en plus de de tout ce qui a été
dit elle coûte très concrètement une
entreprise une ETI qui met en place la
loi Sapin 2 elle voit arriver des
conseils qui lui disent bah là alors il
faut le faire bien sinon sa c'est pénal
et cetera donc c'est 200000 300000 €
puis après on on vient pour CRDS je les
ai vu hier ils vous redisent alors pour
déjà commencer à mettre tout en clair
c'est 150 à 200000 € c'est c'est ça la
réalité d'une entreprise on vient et on
additionne une couche sur une couche sur
une couche et on dit c'est pas grave pas
d'impact pas de mesure d'impact est-ce
que c'est utile la loi sa c'est
peut-être utile pour les entreprises qui
sont dans des marchés publics et cetera
est-ce que c'est utile pour toutes les
entreprises est-ce que c'est utile de la
même manière pour une très grande une
ETI une PME et cetera est-ce qu'il faut
pas adapter et là on a vrai un vrai un
vrai manque de de de stratégie qui qui
aboutissent à quoi à rendre nos
entreprises pas compétitive en France
par rapport à l'environnement européen
pas compétitive en Europe par rapport à
l'environnement mondial et donc un
affaiblissement un appauvrissement dont
souffre à la fin de la journée les
Français hein et les Européens donc ça
c'est le le le le point sur la
compétitivité la souveraineté écoutez je
le redit on a mis en France un système
de droit de douane à l'envers on a mis
en France un système de droit de douane
à l'envers on taxe les entreprises
françaises c'est c'est le contraire des
droits de douanes c'est on a mis on taxe
plus les entreprises françaises ou
étrangères qui produitent sur le
territoire avec tous les toutes les
externalités positives que ça peut que
ça peut générer par rapport à cell qui
produisent à l'étranger c'estune
entreprise française d'ailleurs peut
très bien réussir hein mais en
produisant à l'étranger pas en
produisant en France si elle produit en
France elle se prend alors quand elle
est très petite elle est encore à peu
près protégée il y a des seuils et
cetera dès qu'elle passe ce seuil
qu'elle arrive à la taille moyenne PME
elle se prend la rafale du coup elle
grandit plus en plus elle peut pas se
transmettre donc donc elle est elle est
bloquée et elle passe pas la taille et
puis vous avez plus de grandes
entreprises ou moins de grandes
entreprises et ça qu'est-ce qu'il en
résulte un un appauvrissement collectif
qui pénalise pas les entreprises pas les
entrepreneurs mais l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de la collectivité c'est ça
ce qu'il faut comprendre qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour reprendre la
souveraineté pas forcément faire des
grands plans ou distribuer des
subventions ce qu'il faut faire on vous
on construit pas une usine parce que on
vous donne des subventions une usine
c'est pour 20 ans vous allez construire
une usine parce que vous êtes dans un
environnement où vous pensez que vous
allez pouvoir produire et vendre un
produit de manière compéti si vous
pouvez pasah vous allez pas construire
l'usine vous aurez pas de
réindustrialisation qu'est-ce qu'il faut
pour reprendre la souveraineté française
il faut simplement réaligner la France
sur l'environnement européen c'est pas
une politique de l'offre c'est une
politique du réalignement compétitif la
France c'est un pays extraordinaire on
est créateur d'entreprise inventeur
ingénieur on a un track reccord
d'invention qui est formidable et
qu'est-ce que on on a trois façades
auocéanique on est l'un des pays les
plus agréables à vivre de l'Union
européenne on a tous les atouts pour
être l'un des pays les plus performants
et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait collectivement
on a rendu la la production
l'investissement le travail en France
pas pas compétitif là où ù les autres
les autres pays c'est pas une question
non plus de dépense publique hein c'est
une question de de choix sur qui on fait
porter la dépense publique on fait
porter la surdépense publique française
sur les entreprises mais c'est une folie
en économie ouverte et donc le résultat
de ça c'est l'appauvrissement
collectif merci merci monsieur le
Président et merci beaucoup madame et
Messieurs de votre présence ce matin et
d'avoir donné ces explications je
voulais juste apporter une toute petite
précision il a la simplification des
normes et vous l'avez dit il y a la
différenciation d'application entre les
petites les moyennes et les très grandes
entreprises à la rigueur on peut faire
comme essayie de faire en ce moment les
Pays-Bas si un petit peut le faire un
grand peut le faire et ils essayent de
mettre en place des normes qui
correspondent aux petites entreprise qui
après c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
les grandes de le faire merci beaucoup
et et on va passer à notre deuxième
table ronde et et on n pas fini de
travailler ensemble vous les
sujets
vous êtes actuellement la seule personne
dans cette
conférence
avec une